we had an absolutely stunning
blockbuster weekend of news and I am
going to try to get to as much of it as
possible on today's program let's first
start with what has been a sort of slow
drip drip drip for the last two years
about what the FBI knew what the FBI
suspected about Donald Trump's Russia
connections and also how they've been
investigating it is something we've
slowly learned about over time so for
example we find out there's a new player
in the Russia scam and then we learn
that oh actually Robert Muller has
already been investigating this person
already or we hear okay a plea deal has
taken place and then we learned that oh
actually that individual has been
cooperating with Moeller for the last
six months and has had 12 interviews
with Muller's team or whatever but small
leaks of information or drips of
information over the weekend we learned
something exponentially more outrageous
which is that right after Donald Trump
fired James Comey the FBI was so worried
about Donald Trump's erratic behavior
that the FBI opened an investigation
into whether Donald Trump was working
for the Russians against American
interests the New York Times in an
absolutely bombshell piece of
investigative reporting is citing
multiple former law enforcement
officials and others familiar with the
investigation in this just incredible
article that the FBI was investigating
the president for potentially being a
Russian asset shortly after he was
inaugurated President of the United
States now I wanna short-circuit the
emails I know I'm going to get a Russian
asset and a Russian agent are not the
same thing okay no one is suggesting
that I've seen so far that Donald Trump
was a Russian agent meaning someone who
was in any kind of formal sense working
for Russian intelligence I don't think
anyone would think Trump would be an
intelligence officer for any country so
I don't think anybody's even making that
claim an asset means someone that is
either knowingly or unknowingly being
used for the benefit of in this case it
would be Russian interests what this
means is that counterintelligence
investigators were carrying out work to
try to figure out is the president's
behavior a threat to our national
security and I've said it before it's
possible that Trump is or was sort of
proactively involved in this stuff it's
also more realistic that over the
decades Trump was sort of slowly lulled
and pulled into effectively doing
Russia's bidding without even really
knowing that he's effectively working in
on the behalf of their interests and
that's also something that the FBI is
investigating was this happening
knowingly or unknowingly almost every
sentence in this New York Times story is
amazing senior FBI officials were
suspicious of Donald Trump during the
2016 election but they realized they had
the sense the political sense to realize
that if they open up an investigation
into Trump being a Russian asset that
it's so explosive and so sensitive that
they weren't even sure how they would go
forward with it when Trump fired Comey
that sort of crossed a figurative line
with them and it's also really important
to mention along these lines that a lot
of this trouble for Trump is his own
doing I've said before if Trump didn't
tweet about this stuff if Trump didn't
talk about this stuff in interviews he
would be in far less trouble and case in
point from the article it's explained
that one of the things that allowed FBI
investigators to feel that they were
sort of on more solid ground to actually
start this investigation into Donald
Trump was the fact that Donald Trump
publicly said more than once that he
fired call me to interfere with the
Russia probe that added a specific
possible criminal element obstruction of
justice that public statement is what
sort of opened the door for the FBI to
say at this point we have much more
solid non-political ground on which to
stand and justify this investigation
let's think this through kind of bigger
picture in terms of what it means first
of all as we debate trade policy as we
debate Trump tax reform or we talk about
the border wall all of that policy stuff
the president possibly being a Russian
asset
goes above and beyond any of those
policy disagreements this is another
level altogether this should Pat
transcend politics this should not start
to become an issue of whether you like
or dislike Trump's policy this is so
serious that it should transcend all
partisan bickering and disagreement but
I don't think that that's the case
especially considering the approval
rating that Donald Trump still holds
with the Republican base and even if the
Trump Russia Fiasco never took place
there would still be countless things to
go after Trump on but this is important
this is quite significant and I think
the FBI took a look at the events that
transpired and said we have to we have
to investigate this because the
justification the Trump team gave for
firing Comey that never made any sense
and the next day remember after Trump
fired call me he had Russian ambassador
Sergey Lavrov and Sergey Kiss lyac in
the Oval Office and Trump disclosed
classified information to them he said
that we're gonna have a much easier time
now that that nutjob Comey is out
there's plenty of reasons to investigate
everything that justifies the
investigation makes perfect sense so
then we get to is this investigation
closed or is it ongoing I don't know the
answer to that at this point and the
number three is the realization that if
Trump were a Russian asset he'd be doing
exactly what he's doing now right focus
on a border wall to divide America
straight out of the Russian geopolitical
PlayBook allow a record long government
shutdown to go on further dividing
America drop sanctions on Russian
oligarchs check he'd be doing nothing
about Russian military aggression
towards Ukraine well that's exactly what
he's doing he would be as Pat mentioned
spilling secrets to our ally from our
allies to a Russian spy recruiter in the
Oval Office he's doing all of those
things and if you know the story none of
this stuff is shocking go back to the
80s when the KGB helped make Donald
Trump's trip to Russia happen when they
were trying to actively recruit American
business people in positions of power
the Trump family was followed by Soviet
Intel dating all the way back to the
1970s he's talked publicly about maybe
someday running for president all the
way back to the 1980s there is this very
long paper trail that much like the
increase
corroborated Christopher's steel Trump
Russia dossier matches exactly what our
suspicions increasingly are here make of
it what you will for now and hopefully
someday we will know the full truth but
just an absolutely stunning stunning
report from the New York Times